probably no jokes in this one huh maybe
Packer suck dick I fan of the brett farr
please all right buddy they'll give a
shit about the present-day people and
i'd go all day about sports how the
Lions had a nice offseason the Packers
had a terrible offseason and lines are
going to take the division this year so
sorry Green Bay you're going down Beach
Sports I know a lot about sport oh shit
so what do you think about the NFC North
[Laughter]
Detroit is directed by Kathryn Bigelow
written by Mark Boal this is almost like
the completion of our unofficial real
events trilogy editor The Hurt Locker
and zero dark thirty we now have a movie
about the infamous Detroit riots from
the 60s many people were wrongfully
imprisoned wrongfully killed the police
were incredibly brutal lots of looting
crime it was a horrible terrible
everything's complete shit yes what the
time and this movie documents it similar
to the way Hurt Locker and your dark
thirty was filmed there is documentary s
call most paul greengrass ish you know
where it's a lot of shaky cam crash
zooms there isn't anything about the
movie that feels terribly theatrical it
feels very much so like you're watching
a real event and i don't adore Hurt
Locker or zero dark thirty well I think
they're both fine yeah I figure in no
statement
I think Hurt Locker is alright we talked
in the car before going in a song that I
preferred avatar where to win the Oscar
because I'd like to his camera or Jim
Cameron and I wanted that one I wanted
to win whatever lockers all right I like
to do dark thirty more but still I felt
like it was just long and we look great
climax yeah I think it's your doctor is
better too but
there's just something about that movie
that felt like there were so many extra
subplots that were presented for factual
purposes and maybe didn't have to really
add anything to the movie when it comes
to Detroit I would say it's actually my
favorite of those three I think this
movie is pretty horrifying there are so
many sequences where I was just my hands
were just gripped on my knees easily the
most intense scene for myself when I
watch the movie I don't know about you
but the Algiers motel sequence it was
terrifying
a lot of black men are lined up on a
wall and two white women and police
essentially are antagonizing them for
like a few hours really I mean in the
movie it was probably about I would say
in hours where Islam it was a big sequin
you know it's kind of integral to the
movie and they believe that someone
fired a shot out of one of these windows
and someone did sort of you know I don't
a route in case the the viewers don't
know that like the story behind the
event but they spend a very long time
beating these men forcing confessions
out of them and murders occur and it's
it's terrifying it's it's horrific Lee
sad that this occurred and it is a very
long scene it's kind of the heart of the
major drama of the movie most of the
tension revolves around that moment and
it does go on a while yeah it didn't
bother me though because I was so sucked
into it I'm curious what you thought
about I was sucked into a to however I
just felt I actually talked with flick
pick before we trust' record for this
review and I told him I felt like this
movie would have been better if it
wasn't a movie if it was a stage play
the film starts off with a little bit of
intro about the riots you're kind of
thrown into the mix yeah but the whole
film really is that hotel stuff then
afterwards there's some resolution of
stuff but it keeps like dragging on and
on I felt like if it was just tired and
based more so on the actual hotel stuff
on stage because it's not that's all it
is like one room essentially they go in
other places but if it was contained to
that kind of like area on stage I felt
like it'll be way better of a story
interesting I would say that they do set
up the characters throughout the film
like in other places too
there's one character who wants to be a
singer and all of his friends are in a
band and he's about to go on stage and
perform but due to the riots
they're called away and they get sucked
into this horrible event and John boyega
and the film plays a security guard at
like a small shop yeah it's like his
second job
yeah he also works as like I think it
was a mill worker or something or I
worked at like a metal sheet Factory I'm
like that and he is the one guy who's
watching all these atrocities happen and
he's getting some respect from white
cops because he's in a uniform yeah but
you can tell the way they talk to him
it's it's almost like they're talking to
a child like that they're very subtly
antagonizing him like he brings the
officers coffee and they go one guy's
like um um I'm surprised it's actually
pretty good yeah and you cut back to
boyega and he's got this look and he's
like well I didn't have my normal
materials to make coffee for people
sorry and you can tell that he's trying
to find a way to get some humor into the
situation because he knows if he
antagonizes these cops it could easily
go down because they're all not all but
a large majority of the cops depicted in
this movie are just racist assholes yeah
there's a lot of racism and I felt like
that this film could have been like it
could have been better they could have
been anything
um because the film sets up the riots
which I know not much about by know some
the whole reason why things went up to
this point the riots starting was the
schools a lot of people left to the
suburbs a lot of black people in the
city had like very low end jobs like in
factories and stuff black people being
discriminated against and bars so they
therefore went to make their own bars
which is the Blind Pig which you saw at
the beginning of film I got raid that
started the whole right right the whole
party The Blind Pig was if you saw at
the beginning you have a very keen eye
to guys dressed up as like military
dudes the whole party was to celebrate
them coming back from Vietnam or
something yeah but that's just like not
talked about in the film at all and I
felt like
we just had a little bit of settle for
why things are gone up to this point in
the summer or whatever wasn't 67 for
Detroit that we could have got some like
real light shed on the situation because
there's a lot of prejudice like black
people one of the stores they had
payment white and white people for the
department stores in Detroit and all
kinds of stuff like that so yeah it's
true I can I can understand that
actually because there is an opening
sort of animation yeah
that basically quickly montages through
how Detroit the city and the 60s got to
the point where it was where like you
just said all those things and it was
very quick and it's all the animation
choices weird to me like in the first I
actually thought it was some sort of
strange preview that would be shown
before the movie - it was almost like
this weird little Sesame Street
animation like they had these little
paper like they try to make like 2d
paper look like 3d yeah this is doesn't
really mesh with what I was expecting
that being said it's such a quick thing
but like you said it does touch on
probably my one real issue I have with
the movie is that you're you are really
just thrown into the riots besides that
opening montage it opens with like you
said the blind pig bar cops are outside
and it starts so I can see we were
coming from I can see that there isn't
as much light shed on to how the people
got to the state in that in that city
but at the same time I really liked how
it was just boom were in this and I feel
I felt like the heat of that night like
everyone looked sweaty everyone looked
tired yeah I felt like I was there it
felt like I was watching real events
even though I knew a lot of these actors
faces because none of them are treated
like stars yeah Anthony Mackey's in this
movie and he's not treated like a star
you learned something about his
character but he feels sort of like a
real person that's just there and you
feel for him because again I haven't
really been this mad in a long time
watching a movie I was just mad there
are so many things depicting this movie
by these cops and I got honestly say I
got to give it to these actors who
portray the cops because that is an
incredibly hard role yeah will Poulter
plays like the lead high handi grab his
eyebrows yeah yeah he's like the big
like the
oh he threw a particular who basically
rallies all of them to do these really
horrible things he was terrifying on his
movie I thought it was a great
performance really everyone's good John
boyega I thought was excellent too
because he's a really difficult job he
has to sell that he's angry about what
he's witnessing but not let any of the
other people around him see it yeah
that's why it takes him off and like
that in the trailer back to making
Shabbat that I need you to survive at
night yeah it's just like I wonder how
all those pieces played into the film
and like you said any notion buy
anything Becky and he we end up finding
out later in the film who he is whatnot
but uh he kind of stormy mix and like
you said pretty good analysis that no
one's treat like a star like nothing
going thinking yeah think but it's like
no leave these he's part of the story
but it's not like oh alright
no he does mark he doesn't get a grand
wide shot if he enters frame you know
it's just like oh there is and he's a
character in this movie right there's no
sweeping Michael Bay he plays his part
and yeah it treats the story like a
story rather than like a spill I went
into this movie I was unsure because
I've always found zero dark thirty in
her locker at at overrated and so I went
into this movie being like well this is
a story rife with drama but I don't know
how she's going to handle it and some
might find it a little too long I think
you felt that way yeah for sure
now what do you think he would remove
from the movie without giving any
spoilers I mean obviously this is a
historical event but yeah there's text
that comes up in the credit that says
some things had to be a tit for dramatic
purposes because we didn't know
everything yeah so if their characters
or scenes that you feel perhaps could be
removed to make it better I don't know I
think if I were to like write or rewrite
the film I would definitely start off
with something that wasn't like a paper
mache like five minute intro that is
probably my worst but it wasn't it
wasn't that bad but I felt like we
needed one theme of maybe or one of the
main characters like the singer guy or
maybe boyega at the start for five
minutes going in a department store or
the actually you should end up like a
bar like a regular Detroit bar and y bar
teratoma get the hell out it or what you
want served
is kind or something and then go into
the night of that night and see why
blind pigs are created because let
people screaming again so they can't go
to a white bar or just a bar in general
being a screaming against alright people
just make your own bar I'm done and then
the GI people come in is a party for the
J people now people come in then we saw
we start to connect with these people
it's tough for me because whenever I
watch a movie that has historical events
things that actually happened I want to
go in and dissect like what makes it
work as a film like what makes it
entertaining yeah yeah versus what
happens and what needs to be presented
and then when you see like a fictional
movie and you can just pick it apart it
feels more comfortable with Detroit so
many things happen and then they
actually show you recorded footage from
the actual riots yeah and then
photographs taken of dead bodies in the
same way they were just depicted in the
film and when I saw those photos it's
just kind of sunk into my heart that
these things happen maybe not in the
exact way they're depicted but they
happened these people were killed and
there was no evidence to suggest they
did anything and it's it's more
frightening to me than any horror film
that I've seen this year because one of
the things I noticed while I was
watching it
the audience was reacting to seeing
these cops the same way an audience
reacts to Michael Myers popping out of
the bushes this true they were scary
like there's this scene where these two
guys they're trying to get out of the
motel and they're looking for an exit
because they have this one moment where
they can escape
they've been lined up against the wall
with their hands against the wall for
like an hour or two or whatever they
finally see this chance to escape and
they're looking for back rooms and exits
and in the background of the shot you
see this cop like appear at the doorway
and then I can finally run the other way
and I was like that was like straight up
like a hole yeah it was terrifying yes
and it was just a cop the people in
Detroit were not going to give up they
wanted certain things to be just and
right and certain wrongs to be righted
and the cops they're an unstoppable
force of all their weapons
and everything and these two things
colliding it was just a horrific
gigantic clusterfuck of terrible events
yeah and I found that the movie depicted
it well and humanized a lot of the
characters in it well enough for me to
care there's one thing you said about
clusterfuck and that's why I feel like
this film would've been better feels
just a little bit of setup because we
can get to that moment to where the
people right
because if they just riot because of
people got arrested unjustly people can
be like whoa okay but we have like
reasons why it hit to this moment then
like oh shit yeah I want to ride - let
me throw my phone at the screen you know
like I get it it's fucked I can see that
criticism I really can and I kind of
agree with it it's very much so you're
thrown into the mix but I like that
because so many of the citizens in this
movie of Detroit are also just like what
the hell's going on what what is this
this is insanity this is America why is
why is this happening on our streets
there's a crushing sequence which I
don't want to spoil but it involves
someone thinking they saw a sniper in a
window
early on oh yeah that fucking crush me
dude like that with the other fucked the
guy sitting behind that hurt endoscope
oh and that's how I felt the whole
theater yeah the movie impacted me and
it made me mad it made me angry it made
it did its job for me it's it's clearly
trying to give justice to people who
never got it yeah because we've seen
this today a lot a lot you know it's
we're not going to get too much into
that but lots of people have been
wronged and this movie is a loud cry to
give some justice to the stories of
these people to their lives and it
deserves to be seen I think so he talked
about the documentary style which I
haven't seen dark thirty long time I saw
one theaters I saw Hurt Locker once yeah
so once you start off that you know
handheld I liked it I thought was a good
choice look good we're thrown in the mix
very immersive but about two-thirds of
the way through off like I are sick of
this maybe because there's too much
handheld allotting room there's a lot of
cuts maybe that was it
but I overall thought it was a good
choice to do that and you said earlier
about having the real-life footage there
and having to impact you I felt like
maybe that was just maybe a little too
jarring away from the folk really yeah I
didn't feel like I felt like it should
have been just on the people maybe at
the beginning in the end you had that
real-life shit but I don't know I don't
I didn't agree with that creative choice
I knew about the rides and stuff but I
went into the film thinking all right
we're going to not like you to explain
but there's gonna be some kind of thing
to build up to like people don't know
what the hell like it's like people our
age we weren't around the book at 60
like how do people go into this film and
feel about what's going on if they don't
know what happened really but you have
to printed us film knowing the events
and how it happened to really understand
the story it's true and that contradicts
the marketing campaign because the
tagline of the movie is it's time we
knew yeah and it's sort of it reminded
me of a completely different movie the
amazing spider-man I want to say the
amazing spider-man tagline was the
untold story and you know and there was
um been fucking dying you're like yeah
that seems the blame time see your
purpose parents again or any time in
Detroit yeah you do kind of have to have
a base knowledge of the events that
happened that led to its starting but
that's so quick that it didn't bother me
you do have that quick montage in the
beginning and perhaps they screen the
film to somebody and some audience says
I don't know what's happening now robot
so we'll make a last minute crappy
animation at the beginning to explain
some things maybe maybe because that
just felt like a totally different movie
it felt like they just gave it to
somebody else but enough about the
fucking montage that's great I was
fantastic there are also a few
characters in the film that don't really
get much of an arc boyega's character in
particular is one of my favorites in the
movie and a standout but the way it's
character wraps up it's kinda like yeah
just and the reason I have no problem
with this is because sometimes in life
real people just have to deal with
something bad that happened
and sometimes there is no justice yeah
and this movie and the fact that it
exists is almost like the smallest
little amount of justice like look we're
going to give you something until tell
everyone you're you're horrible story
because yeah bad things happen and
unfortunately sometimes there isn't an
amazing cinematic arc that occurs for
those people and so it really didn't
bother me yeah well you know nowadays we
see a lot of negative shit with cops in
the news and meanwhile there are good
cops and was depicted as a sequence of
in the film where there are some good
cops including um the police chief who
calls out one guy I was like great yes
we have like you know yeah
it's um uh a normal cops I left so it
was nice they showed a FPC it wasn't
just like all cops or Nazis in the 67
they had cuz they brought in like the
National Guard they had the one guy
there's a sequence in the film a state
trooper Michigan disagreement with you
know the Detroit Police so in a Detroit
Police like pretty fucking racist back
in the 60s so it depicted this film
depicted pretty damn well yeah but
there's also other people were like I
don't know what's going on and then kind
of turn a blind eye which is actually
pretty much a mirror image of what's
going on real life it's sad and it's
really and that's kind of how relevant
it is it is yeah because there are
sequences where a certain cop might
might be in a position to help and then
they turn and they think about all the
red tape of jurisdiction and you know
well that's National Guard and I'm army
or that yes Detroit PD and and I'm this
other jurisdiction and they don't even
want to go through the red tape and I
could hear the members of the audience
oh oh yeah yeah because that's really
what it's like and that's why the
system's fucked and unfortunately still
is but beyond politics that we can get
into here talking about this movie that
is obviously very politically oh yes
conversation makes total sense that
we're having after what trust me this is
an early review but when you guys see
Detroit you're going to be sitting down
with your friends
same condo yeah you should be to you you
really should it's it's not the best
movie I've seen you know it's not the
movie of the year that you'll probably
see a million times on every poster but
it is a damn good movie I think and one
that honors the people involved with it
I'm going to give Detroit and a - it was
probably regalos like you said it was
probably best film I felt like maybe
someone like John Singleton should've
should have made this movie and maybe he
would have focused it more on a little
bit of buildup and there maybe the hotel
he thought would do a damn good job - I
felt I don't know I felt going out of
theater at six my honest opinion so yeah
another fair match that's fair that's
pretty much kind of where I was was zero
darken and with a Hurt Locker yeah they
were fine
yeah they didn't blow me away this one
for some reason it was so charged oh
yeah I can still recommend it for people
absolutely the environment was just so
hot and energized with with tension that
I was pretty much riveted from from
scene one to the end and like you just
said we're having this discussion you
told people like friendly I'm discussion
of friends yeah the guy next to me is
like a man uh things are coming out here
I'm like a black guy I know they have no
problem dog yeah after hand to is like
yeah what's your name was like I'm Matt
and what you in person yeah like you're
talking about guys like here's a Greek
you'll bring cultures together again
solutely it was like just went Latino
culture culture thanks for watching this
movie us and I was like wow that you're
welcome man and it was like shake hands
I had no idea who he wasn't there he was
our guys I would recommend Detroit check
it out it's very harsh and unforgiving
but I think it's worth a watch
definitely check out matched channel as
well not harsh not unforgiving and is
worth a watch it can be harsh yeah yeah
you can be harsh and unforgiving in the
best way so it is indeed in the best way
guys thank you very much for watching
and as always if you like this Steven
click right here and get stopped my eyes
[Music]